ausgerechnet ausgerechnet in unserer
freien Osterwoche ist es passiert Donald
Trump wurde in New York als erster
Präsident der USA offiziell angeklagt ja
und wie dieses Foto beweist es hat ihm
nicht gefallen ja Filmaufnahmen waren
leider verboten dafür hat Trump aber
jetzt sehr ausführlich geschildert wie
das Personal da seine Daten inklusive
Fingerabdrücke aufgenommen hat und um es
mit einem Wort zusammenzufassen es war
ergreift
professionin murder is and the everybody
it's taff place
sind sie nur so runtergekulativ
freudentränke
ja ansonsten bestimmt Trump jetzt
ständig sein Richter der Richter habe
eine Zitat Trump hatings also eine
Ehefrau die Trump hasst
doch zu Hause selber eine Frau die Trump
haste
da kannst du jedes beliebige Foto von
den nehmen aber gehört dazu natürlich
gibt's auch noch Anhänger Fans die
eisern zu ihm halten seine
Parteikollegin majory Taylor green zum
Beispiel die in New York dabei war um
die hexenjagdhistorisch sagen wir mal
angemessen einzuordnen Präsident habe
ist joining
nose me and Dollar with and present
Jesus Jesus
na klar natürlich Trump ist eine Liga
mit Jesus mindestens
also eigentlich über Jesus weil er ja
viel reicher ist ne
wie zu erwarten war zieht Trump die
opferkarte im Präsidentschaftsrennen und
führt Haus hoch vor allen
republikanischen Konkurrenten
vielleicht wiederholt sich 2024 wirklich
das olle Duell beiden gegen Trump denn
auch der joe hat gerade verkündet dass
er sehr wahrscheinlich noch mal antritt
wirklich jetzt ernsthaft meine
330 Millionen Menschen leben in den USA
oder fühlen sich echt kein anderer als
immer wieder diese beiden
warum warum
[Musik]
nicht er kommt ist jetzt wirklich nicht
als Altersdiskriminierung gemeint
aber ich sag mal schick mehr Dynamik
bisschen mehr Aufbruch für die letzte
Supermacht des Planeten wer schon schön
oder
ist wieder soweit Trump vs beiden Donald
die Orange Mini Faust Trump gegen Joe
the Kalk Biden schon wieder ein
geräumten fight ohne Gnade seien Sie
dabei wenn der schlechteste Verlierer
der Welt zum comebackkampf fliegt wie
immer mit Klopapier am Schuh und der
Titelverteidiger kommt bestimmt auch
irgendwann
in der Pflegeheim also wenn beide da
noch da sind
kommt wirklich wieder so
hier haben sie gesehen das hier hat
übrigens einer von Trumps grenztabilen
Söhnen gepostet eine plumpe ki-fälschung
in der ein mehr von Jüngern Jesus Trump
zum Gericht folgt so nie passiert und
seitdem haben wir direkt die nächste
sehr aufgeregte ki-debatte was kann man
überhaupt noch glauben wenn der Welt in
der sich jeder Dödel mit Hilfe von
billig Software sowas hier basteln kann
betrifft uns in Deutschland ja auch
längst es brauche bessere Regulierung
die Markierung vom KI generierten
Bildern sonst könnten diese gefundenes
Fressen sein für jene die Desinformation
verbreiten wollen
am Sonntag im ZDF Angela lindströmung
neue Liebe auf Hiddensee ja es braucht
tatsächlich eine ganz neue
Medienkompetenz zum Erkennen von solchen
KI generierten Bildern ich zeige ihm als
Profi worauf man achten muss es sind die
Details hier das stimmt fast alles die
beiden haben ja oft haben oft zusammen
an der Ostsee Urlaub gemacht aber dann
schaut mal genauer hin und sieht Merkel
lacht Fake ne oder hier oder hier
Lindner auf dem Lastenrad glaube ich so
gerade noch aber würde er Hafermilch
kaufen never oder hier privat Foto von
mir erster Gedanke
erster Gedanke ja und so kennt man ihn
aber von wegen wenn Sie genau hin gucken
ich habe überhaupt keine gestreifte
Krawatte
es sind die Kleinigkeiten auf die man
achten muss passend dazu haben gerade
viele kluge Wissenschaftler und Elon
Musk ein Entwicklungsstopp für KI
gefordert weil künstliche Intelligenz
schreiben Sie im Worst Case zum
Untergang der Menschheit führen könnte
bisschen viel Dramatik vielleicht oder
Friedemann Weise sieht jedenfalls
deutlich entspannter
computerspaß am Freitag mit Friedemann
und Tini
willkommen bei computerspaß am Freitag
unser Thema heute künstliche Intelligenz
und bei mir zu Gast ziehen nie hallo
Tini hallo menschliche Zellhaufen du
weißt warum ich dich eingeladen habe
Kindheitstrauma bist Quatsch weil die
Uhrzeit krebserregen nein ich habe dich
eingeladen weil du die erste künstliche
Intelligenz in deutschen Fernsehen warst
und dafür kriege ich jetzt ein Bambi
oder wie nein du weißt doch keine Arme
kein Bambi jeder keine Ahnung von k.i
künstliche Intelligenz ist wie die
Dampfmaschine hä aber bei k.i dampft
doch gar nichts hast du das verstanden
nicht kann uns die KI eigentlich auch
irgendwie helfen
zum Beispiel heute schon Roboter
eingesetzt
ganz nebenbei so sagt man hier nehme
sogar den älteren die Angst vor moderner
Technik und sorge dafür dass auch die
Enkel immer öfter zu Besuch kommen
also ich sehe da nur Probleme beim
nächsten Stromausfall ist dann wieder
die Frage wer kriegt jetzt den Notstrom
der Roboter oder das Beatmungsgerät
typisch Mensch immer nur das Schlechte
sehen ich glaube ihr seid einfach zu
dumm für den Fortschritt oh das stimmt
doch nicht seit Jahrzehnten arbeiten wir
daran dass uns Computer den Alltag
erleichtern eine Fernbedienung und da
steht ein Fernsehgerät ich kann jetzt
umschalten aber ich kann das auch von
hier ausmachen nämlich nehme ich mir
eine Fernbedienung Aufrufe auf dem
Bildschirm und sage dann anschließend
zwei Fernbedienung
Computer fällt dir nicht so leicht in
die so verritze verstehe das Ding ist
wenn man euch Kies dann mal die großen
Fragen stellt dann wird's ja auch ganz
schnell dünn
das weiß ich nicht aber ich kann das
hier ist
und das nennt sich jetzt die Intelligenz
das weiß ich nicht aber ich kann das
hier
solange ihr nur tanzt ist ja okay
schlimm ist wenn KIS Menschenleben
gefährden hinter einem parkenden Auto
kommt gleich eine fußgängerpuppe hervor
kommt das Auto rechtzeitig zum Stehen
nur ein Einzelfall denk lieber mal dran
was du alles schönes erleben kannst
bevor dich die KI United so manche
Beziehung geht über Freundschaft hinaus
Meister und über Liebe Meister
Combo hat eine KI zu Frau ich bin da
willkommen ich habe kein Interesse mehr
an richtigen Frauen
klingt interessant wie wäre es mit uns
beiden Tini zum Gurkenglas habe ich auch
noch zu Hause
Menschengesicht ich habe jetzt ab
tschüss tschüss wir lernen daraus
künstliche Intelligenz und menschliche
Gefühle passen nicht zusammen wir
sollten KI nur für das nutzen was sie
kann nämlich knallharte Fakten liefern
deshalb habe ich vorhin Chat GPT gefragt
in welcher Partei ist Bernd höcke und
die KI hat geantwortet Bernd höcke ist
Mitglied der Alternative für Deutschland
AFD und dann habe ich gefragt in welcher
Partei ist Björn höcke und die Antwort
ich schwöre es stimmt es gibt keine
Person namens Björn höcke ich vermute
dass es sich um einen Tippfehler handelt
und Sie Bernd Türke meinen es gibt also
doch noch Hoffnung tschüss
gute Besserung
[Applaus]
[Musik]
komm wir müssen Strom sparen macht die
Kamera aus Jürgen heute machen wir Asma
abonniert den Kanal für den nächsten
Schimpfwort